today we're canceling zania jones he's a
transgender activist
self-proclaimed science writer who
recently presented the argument for
potentially putting all
children on hormone blockers now just
for a little context and background here
jones runs a youtube account
uh i'll give you a little taste of that
just you know just so you understand
who this is coming from this is jones
and some other person a couple years ago
reacting to a tucker carlson segment
which itself the segment was reacting to
jones statement
that straight men are transphobic for
not wanting to date trans women
and this is what zania jones had to say
about that listen
i feel like this is just his way of
saying
oh you expected people to just
re-examine
some belief that they hold about a
marginalized group
oh you you just you just all wanna [ __ ]
us that is it
no the entire reason i brought this up
was because there are
so many street guys who are into us
there are a ton of people who would be
into us but they have hang-ups about it
because they think oh trans women aren't
women
which is false because trans women are
women
obviously if they could get past that
then maybe they'd realize that they
could have a really good time with us
i am trying to help them here
people who like trans women or might
like trans women
but have issues with it because of
everything that society
says uh okay you you yeah there you go i
don't think we need to watch more than
that
uh just just very quickly
no there are no straight men who
are into you or could be by definition
i mean by definition if you're a
straight man you are attracted to
biological females if you're attracted
to anything but biological females and
you're a man you're not a straight man
by definition so there you go there's
jones
um jones has declared that children now
this is this is this is the new thing
jones has declared that children should
not be forced to undergo
the permanent and irreversible changes
that come with their own puberty
without first quote a professional
evaluation
suggesting that a child's natural
process of growth and maturity
somehow constitutes a human rights
violation jones says that
the argument that children cannot give
appropriate consent for hormone blockers
necessarily leads to the conclusion
that we should be quote putting every
single cis and trans person on puberty
blockers until they are able to offer
quote informed consent
to go through puberty jones presents
puberty as
a choice and one that every child should
have the right to
accept or decline and in order to bring
about this utopia apparently children
should all
be drugged by default now this is quite
insane of course it's
hard to know where to begin and
explaining why it's insane
but one crucial point to make is that
puberty is just
one stage in and facet of
human development if if
if puberty violates consent then my
bones
violated my consent by making me six
feet tall
actually six foot one at least that's
what i say certainly my metabolism has
committed an unspeakable
crime against me by slowing down without
asking first and ensuring that i can no
longer eat at cinnabun without
the evidence showing up around my
midsection in fact even as i
as i say these words my heart is pumping
blood without asking permission my liver
has taken it upon itself to filter blood
regardless of my personal preferences i
must also note with special
disappointment that
uh my body has never sprouted wings so
that i can fly in spite of my repeated
demands
to that end see i exist here in this
body
on this planet in this reality as this
person and almost
everything about my body this planet and
this reality exists
exists independent of how i feel about
it
our consent cannot be violated by nature
because nature is outside the realm of
consent
looters who destroy your store have
committed a crime against you
but a hurricane that destroys your store
has not
you just like you are not oppressed or
victimized by
a natural process occurring in or to
your body
even ones you don't like even death
itself
because this is all a part of being a
human person
and to say that you a human person are a
victim of being a human person
is incoherent now on the other hand
you can be a victim of and have your
consent violated by
artificial substances intentionally
introduced into your body in order to
halt your natural growth
if these drugs are given to you as a
child when your brain has not yet
developed
to the point where it's able to properly
evaluate all the options and make a
truly informed choice
then you are a victim something is being
done
to you artificially by another conscious
agent
and you did not really choose it because
you are not able to make those sorts of
choices
and this is science we're talking about
the prefrontal cortex the region of your
brain heavily involved in decision
making discernment
evaluating choices and so on is not
completely online until the age of 25 at
the age of 9 or 10 or 12
it's not even close to fully operational
that's why children cannot be entrusted
to make
any life-altering decisions for
themselves at all
this is also the whole reason why we say
it's rape for adults to have sex with
children
no matter what the children say the
child cannot choose
a sexual relationship with an adult
because they cannot know what it entails
what the consequences will be
what it all means this very same logic
clearly means that pubescent children do
not take
drugs they are given drugs
if an adult having sex with a child is
not having sex with him but raping him
then an adult giving hormone pills to a
child is not medicating him
but poisoning him but the one thing i
will say
for the demented and evil idea presented
by zania jones
i'll say that it's entirely consistent
with every other demented and evil item
on the radical lgbt agenda
in fact it's the logical conclusion of
those things
if sex is assigned at birth by
unspecified nefarious forces
then puberty is part of that unfair
assignment
if we must break free from this
assigning process
by letting children choose their gender
then they should be able to choose
when and if they undergo puberty
zinaya's point
is inescapably inescapably correct
if you accept the underlying trans
narrative
many people in our culture do accept it
or pretend to accept it
because they're too scared to be honest
about what they really think and that
means
that compulsory hormone pills for all
children
is not as far-fetched as it sounds we
are marching on our way
to that destination as we speak well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
walsh show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content